سينعقد مجلس الشيوخ حيث يمكن لمحكمة
عزل
[الموسيقى] التي
تلاحق هؤلاء الشهود أن
تؤجل بالتأكيد محاكمة مجلس الشيوخ
وتجر أجسادنا إلى
معركة قانونية طويلة ومعقدة حول
الامتياز الرئاسي ، يبدو أن قواعد ماكونيل
قد صممها الرئيس ترامب
للرئيس ترامب.  يطلب من مجلس الشيوخ
الإسراع في أسرع وقت ممكن
ويجعل الحصول على الأدلة صعبًا قدر
الإمكان ، فكر في الأمر ،
فمن المنطقي
أن يكون دليلًا قاطعًا لعزل رئيس الولايات
المتحدة ثم يأتون إلى هنا في
اليوم الأول ويقولون لك  تعرف على ما
نحتاج إليه من المزيد من الأدلة ، فنحن مستعدون
لعرض قضيتنا ، ونحن على استعداد لاستدعاء
شهودنا ، والسؤال هو هل
تسمح لنا بعدم تقديم حجة واحدة حول
سبب عدم وجود شهود
ومستندات تتحدث عن مجلدات ، شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
أي تعليق يمثل والدك سلامًا
أي تعليق يلتقي والدك
بقادة العالم أهم
الأشخاص في العالم و  نحن
نعيد الأعمال الهائلة في الولايات
المتحدة وكلهم هنا لرؤية
الآخرين مجرد خدعة إنها مطاردة الساحرات
التي تجري منذ سنوات
[موسيقى]
صوت مجلس
النواب لمساءلة رئيس الولايات المتحدة
الولايات للمرة الثالثة فقط في
التاريخ الأمريكي ،
يُتهم دونالد جي ترامب بإساءة استغلال
سلطته وعرقلة عمل الكونغرس الآن
، يجب على مجلس الشيوخ أن يقرر ما إذا كان
سيدينونه ويطرده من السلطة ،
وقد حدث الكثير ليصل بنا إلى هذه النقطة ،
دعونا ننظر إلى الوراء.  كيف بدأ كل شيء
الآن أنت تعرف أن قصة
الرئيس ترامب جمد المساعدة العسكرية
لأوكرانيا في يوليو / تموز عندما تحدث مع
الرئيس الأوكراني عبر الهاتف ويطلب
منه التحقيق مع منافس سياسي جو
بايدن بعد وقت قصير
من تلقي المفتش العام لمجتمع المخابرات
مايكل أتكينسون
شكوى المبلغين عن المخالفات التي تزعم أن
الرئيس ترامب ضغط على أوكرانيا
للتدخل في انتخابات 2020
وحاول البيت الأبيض التستر على الأمر الذي
يرسله أتكينسون  الشكوى المقدمة إلى
القائم بأعمال مدير المخابرات الوطنية
جوزيف ماكغواير وهنا
تفسد الأمور قانون المبلغين عن المخالفات الذي ينص
على أن المدير سيرسل الشكوى إلى
الكونجرس لكن ماكجواير لا يفعل ذلك لأن
هذه الشكوى مختلفة عن معظمها لأنها
تتعلق برئيس ماكغواير
رئيس  قد تخضع الولايات المتحدة ومحادثاته
مع زعيم أجنبي وتلك
المناقشات لامتياز تنفيذي
يتم حجبه عن الجمهور
لأغراض الأمن القومي أو
لحماية المداولات الداخلية ، وهو
امتياز ليس لدي
سلطة التنازل عنه بدلاً من
إرسال الشكوى  إلى الكونجرس يطلب
من البيت الأبيض التوجيه ، فانتقل
إلى موضوع الشكوى للحصول على المشورة
أولاً حول ما إذا كان يجب عليك
تقديم الشكوى إلى الكونجرس ، أعتقد أن
كل شيء هنا في هذا الأمر غير
مسبوق تمامًا حيث يقوم ماكجواير بإرسال
الشكوى إلى وزارة العدل
في هذا  نقطة عملية سرق هذا
عندما مفتش الجينات  قلق
يطلع الكونجرس على وجود
الشكوى ويبدأ مجلس
النواب بالتحقيق
في وجود سلسلة من التسريبات ويتم الإعلان عن
الاتهامات داخل
الشكوى وهذا يضغط على البيت
الأبيض ويؤكد الرئيس ترامب أنه
ناقش جو بايدن  في مكالمته مع
الرئيس الأوكراني ، كانت المكالمة عبارة عن
شركة رائعة ، هي مكالمة مثالية
حيث يطلق المنزل
تحقيقًا لعزل الرئيس ، ويجب أن يحاسب الرئيس ، فلا
يوجد أحد فوق
القانون في اليوم التالي الذي
يصنف فيه البيت الأبيض D  نص
المكالمة ويتم إرسال شكوى المبلغين عن المخالفات
إلى مجلس النواب بالكونغرس ويبدأ الديمقراطيون
في استدعاء موظفي السلطة
التنفيذية مهددين بتوجيه اتهامات بالازدراء إذا
لم
يحضروا ، يدفع البيت الأبيض قائلاً إن العملية برمتها غير
دستورية وتنتهك
حق الرئيس في الاستحقاق.  معالجة
القرار الذي تم اعتماده دون اعتراض
، يتم وضع اقتراح إعادة النظر
على t  قادرًا على ذلك ، يُضفي المنزل رسميًا على
تحقيقه من خلال التصويت الذي من المتوقع أن
يتماشى مع الخطوط الحزبية ويعقد
سلسلة من جلسات الاستماع الخاصة والعامة ،
وجدت أن المكالمة الهاتفية يوم 25 يوليو / تموز غير عادية
لأنه على عكس
المكالمات الرئاسية الأخرى التي لاحظت أنها
تضمنت مناقشة ما بدا أنه
أن تكون مسألة سياسية داخلية لدي
مخاوف وكان من واجبي الإبلاغ عما إذا
كان هناك مقايضة كما أشهدت
سابقًا فيما يتعلق
بمكالمة البيت الأبيض المطلوبة واجتماع البيت الأبيض
الإجابة هي نعم كان الجميع
في الحلقة التي ينص عليها الدستور
يمكن مقاضاة الرئيس بسبب
الجرائم والجنح الجسيمة ، لكن هذا لا
يحدد ما تعنيه هذه المصطلحات ، الأمر
متروك للكونغرس ويقرر
مجلس النواب المضي قدمًا.
دونالد جيه ترامب
بارتكاب جرائم وجنح جسيمة
ويتوجه إلى قاعة مجلس النواب
للنقاش.  تصرفات الرئيس
المتهورة تجعل من المساءلة
أمرًا ضروريًا
لأنه لم يمنحنا أي خيار في تصويت
تاريخي يتهمه مجلس النواب
الرئيس ترامب بإساءة استخدام سلطته
وعرقلة الكونجرس الآن ينتقل إلى
مجلس الشيوخ لمحاكمة حيث
ستكون هناك حاجة إلى أغلبية الثلثين
لإدانته  وإقالته من منصبه
في غضون ذلك ، يستعد الرئيس ترامب
لإعادة انتخابه في عام 2020 ، مما يعني أنه
يجب على الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين تحقيق
توازن حرج بين متابعة
واجباتهم الدستورية وحماية
حياتهم السياسية.